你即將看到的內容會刷新你整個股市官
讓你震驚自己啊
你要知道世界上有一群人
他們研究股票的方式和大部分投資人
完全不一樣
他們不研究公司的財務狀況
也不研究任何的數學公式跟指標
甚至不太在乎價格漲到哪裡
他們最在乎的只有一件事
時間
當所有專家都在告訴你
不要預測整個股價的高低點時
他們卻在自力研究股價什麼時候
最容易發生轉折
他們讓你知道你什麼時候買股票
可以買在地點
什麼時候賣股票
可以賣在高點
更離譜的是
這群人居然真的發現
股市存在著一種隱藏的時間秩序
很多重要的高點和地點
都不是隨機出現的
他們會按照某種周期
不斷的重複發生
這套理論有一個很特別的名字
叫做三角周理論
今天這部影片
我想帶你認識這套
在投資圈
充滿神秘色彩的理論
它到底在研究什麼
為什麼認為
漲跌存在固定的周期
為什麼2026到2027年
台股將非常危險
最重要的是使用這套理論
抓到股票的高地點的四個步驟
我敢跟你保證
當你看完這部影片
你看待股票的方式
會和過去完全不一樣
因為你將發現金融市場
有史以來最重大的秘密
我是小王子
20年股票實戰交易員
靠股票當充跟波段
連續五年獲利破千萬
我會用你聽得懂的語言
幫你看透股市裡
沒有人願意說出的里程邏輯
三角桌理論
最初是由一個人發現的
他叫吉姆史洛文
他花了很多年的時間研究股市的這套規律
最終整理出完整的理論架構
他後來把這套理論賣給一個知名的買家
叫做威爾斯·威爾德
也就是RSI指標發明者
他花了100萬美元
買下這套三角洲理論
在那個時代
100萬美元是個天文數字
威爾斯拿到理論之後
他們研究協會裡出現的叛徒
私下把這套理論公開反授
我也是經過深思熟慮後得出一個結論
與其讓這套理論繼續在黑市裡流傳
不如公開出書讓所有人都能平等的取得這些知識
於是三角洲理論就這樣出現在你我眼前
也就是說三角洲理論本來是一個不開被公開的秘密
而你很快就會知道為什麼威爾斯本人不希望公開
接下來我們就來公開這個秘密
我先問你一個問題
你認為股價的漲跌是有秩序的嗎?
什麼叫做有秩序?
假如股價在8月7號出現高點
每過一個月9月7號 10月7號 11月7號
也應該要出現高點
這就是秩序
所有人都會告訴你
不可能
我們無法預測高低點
但三角洲理論完美的證明了
股價的漲跌是有秩序的
理論的邏輯是這樣的
股市由人組成
而人的情緒和行為
並不是完全隨機的
我們的生活節奏
消費習慣
投資情緒
都會受到時間周期的影響
最明顯的例子